have you ever thought about um
because i feel like people would pay you
to come and speak to them right i feel
like you could be like a
motivational speaker man
no like i always see like um
there's like motivational speakers who
have crazy backgrounds you could go
speak at conventions you could speak a
leadership [ __ ] like i feel like you got
a crazy story i actually did that a
little bit i did that a little bit with
a company that i worked for when i first
came home from the feds
um they had me going to like schools and
talking to the kids
and it was funny because you know a lot
of the teachers will sit there and look
at me like oh [ __ ] who are we bringing
into our school but when i leave
those kids would be asking for me
they would get at you know my boss where
i worked at and ask him hey is he coming
back the teachers would be like we need
him back because
now this kid that didn't listen to me
for all these years is listening to me
and now this like they really enjoyed
what i brought to the table and funny
that i ended up catching a violation
um through my probation officer that
that you know
went and said that oh i made an album
while i was on probation which i
shouldn't have done the baldacci code
which is my album
um well you weren't even allowed to
record nah because he said that when did
you get the time to go record that when
you're supposed to be at work when
you're supposed to be this when you
don't have money for this or you don't
have money for that like i came home
that's my music carried
the money yeah like i didn't need to
have money people were hitting me up hey
come record at our studio we got you you
don't got to pay nothing like that type
of [ __ ] that's what they didn't
understand he was looking at my social
media and like you got a bentley on your
last post you got money to pay for these
these house arrests or this dad like i'm
like bro that's not my bentley and once
you see that
you know once you look at that and
picture that like that you're you're
turning into a fan bro like you know
what i'm saying like this is just part
of i can see yeah i you know what i mean
like this is what you're what this is
what also people are you could record at
home in your closet for [ __ ] right
three hundred dollars at guitar center
right and he didn't understand that you
know i had to kind of explain to him so
he finally
took me to jail for that and took me to
jail for being with my son's mom because
she was on on federal custody as well
but when we got there she was pregnant
my judge was like okay what is he here
for he's like oh you know he's here for
the violation for recording this album
and talking about gang stuff and murders
and whatever he thought that i was
talking about he just put his little
concoction of stuff in his brain right
oh he's this is what he's talking about
then he said oh he's also in violation
for being with
the kid's mom or the my pregnant baby
mom and
for missing a drug test so those were
the three things that i was there for
she kicked out two of them she kicked
out the main
cd
album thing she kicked out the baby mama
thing and all she left me was the
mystery drug test he
asked for a year
added to my
probation and a year more in custody he
wanted me to go back to jail so she said
you know what uh i have
27 letters from teachers and from all
these people saying
how he's such a good guy and how he's
doing so well with himself
should i believe the 27 letters of
people or should i believe you like
she's like i'm kind of
like struggling to see who i'm going to
believe and also i believe it was a
comment on social media that kamala
harris had left
um she left a comment on your social
media not exactly mine but the people
that were like
that i worked for before
they um they put up a post of me going
to speak to the kids and she left a
comment like saying that's great or
that's awesome or some so you know of
course they screenshot it they use that
towards my advantage as well she she's
seen that
she's into the time that kamala harris
is the this was before she's the
attorney general or a district attorney
or something i don't think she was what
she is now right right well she
definitely wasn't vice president but at
a point in time i think she was attorney
yeah i think that's when she was an
attorney general or something like that
so they said she locked up a lot of
people yeah that's crazy yeah so she i
mean it helped me in a sense though
that's great going forward you know um
the the judge she was a sister you know
what i mean she was cool she was
actually taking the time to
read she actually applied herself to all
of the information she did she really
like some judges will just look at the
probation officer look at me
yeah
look at this guy oh yeah i don't care
what you say you got going like you're
gone so that helped me and
instead of giving me a year in custody
and a year added to my time she gave me
90 days in custody and
termination of probation so that kind of
was a blessing it was the best because
you'd rather go knock that three months
out
and then do this live free you know
reading the book yeah i mean like i'm
not even tripping and that helped me
because you know i went and did it and
when i came home i didn't have no tail
no worries you know